de l'autre autres
pour vous
vous vous demandez qu'on vous appelle
écrivaine
épatez écrivent franchement je suis
conducteur de l'humanité tout d'abord
je trouve que le langage symbolique
c'est très important d'être à l'aise
dans les mots il se dit gêné par un
féminin comme on l'a toujours été au
moyen-age entre les ministères on
était une bande reste sont des thèmes
qui se rendent
et tout à coup aujourd'hui par un
espèce de réflexe les yeux
dans les productions de prestige parce
que les professions ordinaire ça passe
très bien on est agricultrice mais on
est écrivain dès qu'on monte en grade
alors je trouve que c'est vrai vous dire
que la dignité de la fonction
oui tout à fait
laissez les fonctions de prestige en
ayant juste affirmé le patron oui et al
à l'état dans les postes supérieures
mais madame le secrétaire d'état
la doyenne des français sur les
centenaires madame le doyen de
l'université
donc c'est pas la langue qui refusent ce
sont les têtes
et on voudrait simplement régulariser
pas changé de langage
faire fonctionner le féminin pour les
noms de métiers c'est tout alors vous
battez contre la misogynie ou le sait
depuis longtemps qu'il publie
c'est cette même assurance
charles duchaine
tous ces avantages d'un certain nombre
de français figurent pas piquée des
hannetons
des hommes sur les femmes l'impact ce
que voulait dire par là que la langue
française actuellement
on peut dire et les cyclistes
elle est machiste
et d'ailleurs - le comité de l'europe
les secours j'aime toutes les deux de
prendre des décisions pour féminiser
le langage parce qu'on ne sait plus si
on s'adresse à
à une femme ou un homme portant 10% le
directeur de tels services au lieu de
dire la directrice madame le pour le
moment
ça ne sonne c'est la confusion des
genres alors ces grandes entreprises en
recommandé aux états membres de toute
l'europe de féminiser les noms de
métiers et de dire la déléguée ce
qui n'est pas une révolution la
conseillère fédérale en suisse etc et
en france en est le dernier pays
francophones
à être encore complètement bloqué la
csu
d'ailleurs comme on l avant-dernier
d'europe pour la représentation des
femmes au parlement y a pas de mal
pas celui des relations hommes-femmes
mais le domaine de la langue et le
domaine du pouvoir où les hommes
s'accrochent à leur place
plus d'ouvrir la porte aux femmes
complètement même ton sexe